a lot of people are scratching their
heads over a trump truth social post
that came out yesterday and it was a it
was a picture half the screen is Elvis
Presley and half the screen is Donald
Trump and uh tweet it says
uh lots of people have said that I look
a lot like Elvis for so many years many
people have been saying that what do you
think people are scratching what what is
he even talking about this is is beyond
policy this is my favorite part of
Trump's political
style because this kind of a
post is funny it's weird and it's
totally disarming the the libs have to
respond to it it drives them crazy they
have to call him an idiot and they have
to call him distracted but the thing
that the libs are most upset about is
that it makes it much harder for them to
portray Trump as
Hitler